I've written some example relationships
between two variables in this case
between m and n between a and B between
x and y and what I want to do in this
video is see if we can identify whether
the relationships are a direct
relationship whether they vary directly
or maybe they vary inversely or maybe it
is neither so let's explore it a little
bit so over here we have M over N is
equal to 1/7 so let's see how we can
manipulate this if we multiply both
sides by n what are we going to get and
in general you want to separate them so
that the two variables on different
sides of the equation so you can see is
it going to meet is it going to be the
pattern let me write it this way M is
equal to K times n this would be direct
variation or is it going to be the
pattern M is equal to K times 1 over n
this is inverse variation and you see in
either one of these they're on different
sides of the equal sign so let's take
this first relationship right now let's
multiply both sides by n multiplied both
sides by N and you get M because these
cancel out is equal to 1/7 times n so
this actually meets the direct variation
pattern it's some constant times n m is
equal to some constant times n so this
right over here is direct that they vary
directly this is direct variation let's
see a B is equal to negative 3 so if we
want to separate them and we could do it
with the either variable we could divide
both sides I don't know let's divide
both sides by a we're going to done it
with by B if we divide both sides by a
we get B is equal to negative 3 over a
or we could also write this as B is
equal to negative 3 times 1 over a and
once again this is this pattern right
here one variable is equal to a constant
times 1 over the other variable in this
case our constant is negative 3 so the
over here they vary inversely they vary
inversely this is an inverse
relationship let's try this one over
here I'll try it in that same color XY
is equal to 1/10 once again let's try to
separate the variables isolate them on
either side of the equation let's divide
both sides by X you could divide by Y
because you're really just trying
find a inverse or direct relationship so
divide both sides by X you get Y is
equal to one tenth over X which is the
same thing as 1 over 10 X which is the
same thing as 1 over 10 times 1 over X
so y is equal to some constant some
constant times 1 over X once again this
is an inverse where this isn't it the y
and x vary inversely let's do this one
over here
9 times M go to that same orange color 9
times 1 over m is equal to n so this
one's actually already done for us and
it might be a little bit clearer if we
just flip this around if we just flip
the left on the right hand side we get n
is equal to 9 times 1 over m n is equal
to some constant some constant times 1
over m so n varies inversely with M
inverse and remember if I say that n
varies inversely with M that also means
that M varies inversely with n those two
things imply each other now let's try it
with this expression over here and this
one's a little bit of a trickier one
because we've already separated the
variables on both hands and then we have
this kind of it's not being if this was
B is equal to 1/3 times a that we would
have direct variation then B would vary
directly with a but in this case we
should have 1/3 minus a and you say hey
maybe there operate opposites or
whatever and it actually turns out that
this is neither this is neither and to
make that point 100% clear let's let's
look at two of these examples in direct
variation if you scale up one variable
in one direction you would scale up the
other variable by the same amount so if
we have X going if X doubles from 1 to 2
when X is 1 or actually I should do this
with M and N that was so M and n so when
and the way I've written it here
although you could algebraically
manipulate it so that one looks more
dependent than the other but in this
situation where n is n is 1 M is 1/7 M
is 1/7 and when n is 7
M is going to be one so you have the
situation that if n is scaled up by
seven then M is also scaled up by seven
or vice-versa sits more of a
relationship I could have expressed n in
terms of M but when you scale one
variable up by seven you also have to
scale up the other variable by seven or
when you scale it up by some amount you
have to scale the other variable by the
same amount so this is direct direct
variation let's take the inverse or when
two variables vary inversely this
situation right over here let's take a
and B when a is equal to 1 B is equal to
negative 3 and we could do it explicitly
right over here we can even go to the
original one when a is equal to 1 we
have 1 B is equal to negative 3 B is
equal to negative 3 now when a if I were
to take a and if I were to let's say I
were to triple it so if I were to
multiply it by 3 so now a is 3 we have 1
over 3 times negative 3 so now B is
negative 1 notice we didn't multiply B
times 3 here now we divided B times 3 or
we should we divided B by 3 I should say
or in other ways we multiply it by 1
over 3 so if you scale up a by 3 you're
scaling down B by 3 so they're varying
inversely what you're going to see in
this neither is that neither of these
are going to be the case so let's try it
out let's try it out I'll do it in that
same green color do it in that same
green so we have a and B so when a is I
don't know when a is 1 what is B 1/3
minus 1 that's 1/3 minus 3/3 that's
negative 2/3 and then let's divide just
for fun let's divide a by 3 so if a goes
to 1/3 so over here we're dividing by 3
or you could say we're multiplying by
1/3 so if a is 1/3 then B is equal to 0
right if a is 1/3 B is equal to 0 so
notice if this was direct variation we
would be multiplying this by 1/3 as well
which clearly we didn't and if this was
inverse variation
if they vary inversely we would be
multiplying by three which clearly we
did it we just got some other number we
actually ended up the the scaling
actually didn't matter what happens is
is that things really just got shifted
by some amount they got shifted by two
thirds so this is neither direct very up
these neither very directly nor in verse
Li this last one right over here